hey how do you do wordsmiths this video
is about the word enforce
n Force it's a verb it means to make
sure that a rule or law is followed you
might usually hear it in the context of
enforcing a law right if I drive too
fast local authorities can enforce the
speed limit by issuing me a speeding
ticket
now the word origin here is kind of a
violent one this word comes from the old
French all foursier which means to use
force on someone or something so en
means in or on
when it's en 99 of the time that means
it has a French origin and sometimes
it'll appear as e m 2.
Force means strength or power It
ultimately comes from a Latin word
Fortis which just means strength so when
you enforce you're using your strength
on someone let's take 10 seconds to come
up with some more English words that
contain an or M and force I'll put on
some music and I'll meet you back here
in 10 seconds
right let's do it
[Music]
all right here's three I came up with
reinforce which means to strengthen
something right to put more force in it
um in code which means to make
information secret or to give
computerized instructions a spy might
carry an encoded letter or I might
convert a video file from one file type
to another using an encoder program
right I'm putting it in or into code
and embolden which means to give someone
confidence right literally to put
boldness in them and I know it's em
there but m means the same thing as n
let us use the force as it were and make
some sentences the Admiral enforced the
law on his enemies but he ignored the
law for his friends so the Admiral made
sure that his enemies had to follow the
law but not his friends there he is
signing a little decree the noun form of
enforce is enforcement which you're most
likely to read or hear in the phrase law
enforcement which is to say the the
police sheriff's department Department
of Justice right law enforcement is
empowered to enforce the law they
represent the power of the state to say
things like hey it's against a lot of
hurt people and if someone hurts people
the law has the power to stop them right
that's what it means to have enforcement
powers
okay you can learn anything
David out